aux côtés des soldats russes affiliés à
l'armée à des entreprises russes ou
encore indépendants plusieurs groupes
paramilitaires opèrent en Ukraine comme
Wagner il recrute grâce à de petites
annonces postées sur les réseaux sociaux
merci nerf ancien militaire prisonniers
ou encore vagabond parmi les milices aux
ordres du pouvoir russe PCM patriote est
attribué au ministère de la Défense et à
Sergei elle serait composée d'anciens
militaires mais aussi d'agents secrets
du GRU
réduite elle a été créée par d'anciens
membres des forces spéciales tandis que
canvoy a été fondé fin 2022 en Crimée
par son chef proclamé Sergueï actionnov
fondé par le nationalistrus
igorment gouchève le groupe
paramilitaire et notre corps opère en
Ukraine depuis 2014 où il s'est fait
connaître pour ses missions
particulièrement violentes
le géant russe déshydrocarbures Gazprom
et lui aussi engagé sur le front
ukrainien à travers plusieurs forces de
sécurité privée pottok Fakel ou encore
platmia enfin le bataillon arc matt est
dirigé par le président de tchétchène
ramirov placé au pouvoir par le
président russe et qui utilise des
milices adeptes de la torture depuis
2016 pour faire régner la terreur dans
son pays en Ukraine le bataillon serait
composé de 12000 hommes dont certains
ont été envoyés en renfort à Rostov au
moment où la Russie faisait face à la
rébellion du groupe Wagner
voilà pour